you're live CH thank you uh good evening
and welcome to this Central planning
committee meeting on Wednesday the 22nd
of uh of November
20123 I declare the meeting
open my name is councelor John driver
and I am the chair of this committee um
my members are are we are streaming this
meeting live as well as recording and by
being present in the meeting you are
giving your consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
could I ask members to avoid approaching
the top table as this could create
interference with the cameras and live
stream please note that the YouTube live
stream sound recording is dependent on
the correct use of the microphones
therefore can I ask that when invited to
speak you remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referencing or referring to
the agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible uh Mr Young could I have
apologies for our absence
please we we don't have any apologies
chair thank you very much uh so on to
item uh agenda item three minutes it's
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on Wednesday the 30th of
August 2023 and found on pages 7 to 10
are approved as a true and accurate
record I so move do I have a second uh
thank you can we agree by asent
members thank you very much on to item
four Declarations of Interest which I
have to read out this statement to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecun interests other
registerable interests and non-
registerable interests relating to items
of business on the agenda having regard
to paragraph 9 and appendix B of the
code of conduct for members members are
reminder that they are required to
disclose any such item as soon as they
become aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting could I have any
Declarations of Interest councelor
stilts thank you Mr chair um agenda item
six non pecary as I do know the
applicant thank you councilor sils
councilor spenley Paula spenley thank
you chair um agenda item number six the
applicant is known to me as a fellow
Trustee of the mod Festival thank you
much any others councelor shy thank you
um agenda item six chair I also know the
applicant okay thank you councelor
Jennings thank you chair um a nonary
interesting agenda item six as I know
the applicant okay thank
you go for number five as
well uh yes yeah so I mean I will ask
number five as well yeah thank you yeah
uh h councelor Miller agenda item number
five and number six again I know the
applic thank you and councelor lei
agenda item five and six as I know the
person involved thank you very much any
other disclosures
coun oh sorry councelor shorty and five
yes I do know the right okay and
councelor
[Music]
lagen thank you chair um I don't have a
a knowledge of five six but I do have
had correspondence with residents um
from s and 8 so I have responded and
acknowledge that that correspondence
thank you all right thank
you counc Spen yes I've also
acknowledged correspondence on items
seven and eight and I should have added
five to the first one
so thank
you cancel
stils I'm going to say exactly the same
right okay can Miller I've had items
seven and eight as well with in previous
correspondence thank
you okay are we there I think we are
just about there I think we can probably
now start uh the meeting prop okay we'll
move on to uh agenda item five then so
uh this can be found on pages
11-
um I I don't believe we've had any
members update relating to this so uh m
Matthews uh if you could present the
report
please thank you chairman good evening
members um those those members who are
here the committee earlier on in the
year may recognize some of some of this
because it's an amendment to um an
application that members
considered so um this is presentation
for joint for items um apologies I've
got the wrong item number and there it
should be five five the top one and six
for the second one um yeah so it's joint
presentation for both but I'll I'll just
do the first one item five first so this
is the um application site and the
application is for a change of use from
office um and a for former treatment
rooms to two short two short-term HED
elects and Associated Works to part of
the first floor front in the High Street
includes the installation of secondary
glazing
this is a um plan showing the location
the application site on the um High
Street um which fronts the High Street
and also v Lane to the
rear um this is the block plan showing
the two holidays in orange and green the
Orange is the orange is primarily the
former offices and the green is
primarily the former treatment
rooms and this is existing first floor
layout
um again got orange and green the same
coloration so the the high straight is
to the to the right on that plan okay
and then we've got some proposed
secondary glazing to the high stre
elevation including the bay window which
was a an issue of contention as part of
the previous appeal but that issue is
now being addressed in terms of the
impact on listed building and then we've
also got some other secondary glazing um
to the to the re side that's to the the
second holiday Le
on some photos I'm sure you're very
familiar with the building on the High
Street so um having reassess the
application in light of the
revised description and the reion the
revision being the addition of a second
holiday letter um it's considered um The
Proposal is no less acceptable than that
considered by the central area planning
committee on the 31st of August in
relation to listed building and living
condition effects taking into account
the additional information submitted to
part of the current application
necessary Financial contribution towards
Rams hasn't hasn't been secured yet but
any further resolution to Grant plan
permission could be subject to section
106 having first being entered into by
the relevant parties and on that basis
the application is recommended for
approval again subject to 106 being
completed and um conditions as set out
in your papers thank
you thank you m Matthews um we have
public participants for this planning
application
and in line with the public
participation scheme I now invite them
to read out uh their submission so I
think we have uh
presentation from uh Mr Farley who's the
agent Mr Farley are
you he's online are you online yes you
can hear me okay uh hopefully you can
also see the
timer is that the case I shouldn't need
it today all right well that's that's
fine anyway you have two minutes you can
see it on the timer uh I will stop you
after those two minutes uh should you go
on but uh hopefully you won't all right
thank you over to you when you're ready
okay thank you uh Mr chair members yes
thank you for the opportunity to address
the committee again and please accept my
apologies for the previous iteration of
this proposal if it was not sufficient
clear in describing what was being
proposed given that the recommendation
for this and the associated list of
building consent application are both
for approval I do not intend to take up
too much time but I would like to take
the opportunity to also thank the
planning officer for the positive
recommendation and for working through
the outstanding issues with us
proactively and
pragmatically however uh and hopefully
this approach will continue through
prompt discharge condition
uh just to clarify on the report that
the unilateral undertaking has been
provided along with monitoring and
checking fee and so officers should be
in a position to issue the plan of
commission imminently if you agree to it
this evening subject to sign off from
your legal department and I'm sure that
the applicant will have a stream of new
visitors spending time and money in
Moren Town Center within a matter of
weeks thank
you uh thank you very much Mr Farley um
members I now invite you to put any
questions or make any comments you have
to the
report any questions or
comments no well in that case uh do we
have a
proposal uh councelor Miller your
proposing we accept councelor Jennings
seconding can I just check are there any
conditions that we would want to apply
If This Were to be
accepted chair um chairman only the ones
that are on the agenda right um okay
which cover um various various issues
and and there the yes um and I can
confirm the draft well a uning has been
submitted but I waiting for legal to say
that it's it's okay so um so that is
that is in hand if you like but hasn't
quite that process hasn't quite been
finalized yet okay um so we've had a
proposal from councilman seconded by
councelor Jennings to accept this
application can I have a vote in favor
of that motion please unanimous thank
you very
much okay um on to item six
then um which can be found on pages
27 to
34 and again m Matthews could you
present the
report
thank you chairman the presentation is
um exactly the same as the previous one
um and just a reminder that it is agenda
item six we're talking about now not not
seven as on on the presentation there
um it's the same application site um
it's the same two units obviously the um
king's head is a a gray to listed
building and therefore the the physical
work to the building require um
disability consent um in addition to the
planning permission
um
uh and these are floor plans existing
floor plans um the main issue of
contention with in terms of the listed
building previously was the um the
installation of secondary glazing to
some of the historic windows on the on
the Frontage of the building but um
further details have been submitted and
our conservation officer is now content
with the details and considers that it
can be done in a way that wouldn't um be
detrimental to the historic significance
of the building so that these are the
ones for the front
as said before and these are ones um I
don't whether you can see but there's
they're numbered down here as the other
windows that would be um given secondary
glazing and that primarily for um noise
attenuation um for the occupiers of the
holiday Els um again the photos so again
it's considered the proposal no less
acceptable than the proposal considered
um back in August by the cow committee
and in relation to listed building
effects um again Tak into account the
addition information which has been
submitted as part of the current
application and on that basis
recommended that listed building consent
is granted um subit to conditions um as
set out in your papers thank you thank
you Mr Matthews uh we don't have any
public participants for this particular
planning application uh so members any
questions
comments no do we have a proposal
councilor Miller you're proposing
I think counselor Nick spenley this time
just got his hand in just quicker so
seconded by councelor Nick spensley uh
so could we vote on that proposal please
that we accept this unanimous okay thank
you very
much okay we now move on um to agenda
item seven P found on pages
35 to
44 um we haven't had a members update in
relation to this so uh Mr Johnson if you
could present the report
please thank you chairman and
members I will be taking the planning
and the listed Building Together under
the same presentation they cover the
same details um except for specifically
what they want members are familiar with
that so um details over the proposal are
found at section three under summary in
terms of location which is north side of
High Street uh within the molden
conservation area it's a three-story mid
Terrace grade two listed building
comprising a mix of ground floor
commercial and first and second floor
residential
the residential Flats at first and
second floors are located towards the
front of the
building so we can see the uh building
there outlined if we just scroll down to
the and again just within the wider
model and High Street
context and block plan scroll down
again okay um got the existing ground
floor so the front of the building is to
the left um
the I suppose the smaller
leftand um quarter of the um plan or
third of the plan U that comprises the
element to which the residential are
above on the first and second floors the
remainder is a um uh sort of contiguous
unit which which comprises the bulk of
The Proposal
site so here we have the proposed ground
floor
um again just to the to the bottom where
we can see the arrows and it clearly
says there location of the condenser
units that's along that southern um or
rather that
Eastern uh but Southern on our on the
plan um uh external uh uh
alleyway
and just above that um again to the
right hand side um is the kitchen
area just sort of in that area
there the main um area towards the
center that's that's comprises the seat
and the area and the bar so we just
scroll down
again and this uh proposed ground floor
layout
plan um pretty straightforward there we
can see the seat in the area again
kitchen to the right toilets to the top
left hand side and a bit more seat into
boards the
front can just scroll down
again the existing vent the existing
ventilation there is a ventilation
system within the building which will be
utilized as part of the proposals um and
enhanced as per the details in the
application and which I will touch on um
further with the presentation but we can
see the uh the ventilation system uh uh
in the
kitchen um and again just to remind that
there is no residential above this
element um the ventin is to the uh rear
of the building which is to our right
hand side again I'll touch on that in a
bit more detail but also set out within
the report the ventilation the uh Inlet
and the extraction units um and and any
lowlevel discharges towards that rare
area there
scroll down again again this is a this
is a section um showing the kitchen area
and showing the nature of the
ventilation
system again that's just another section
sorry in another section of of the
same we got the uh existing and proposed
um there are no changes to the um to to
the frontage um except for under the um
the uh advertisement consent where there
will be some adverts but that's the only
change otherwise to the fabric it will
remain as it
is this is the existing side uh which is
the East
Elevation and again this is the proposed
side and this was to the the bottom part
of the of the floor plan that we saw
earlier and we can see the location of
the
condensing um units
um they so we just just scroll back up a
little bit and we can see that that they
are enclosed with acoustic with an
accoustic enclosure to um
attenuate um any noise um that they make
I mean these are these are high level
condensing units which are fairly low
level in noise emission in any event um
but uh further noise emissions uh again
are are are are again attenuated U
because of the design of the incl
oses
uh the existing and proposed other side
no changes
there uh and this is the rear we can see
the
existing um and to the proposed uh to
the to the left hand side we can see the
size elevation of the condensing
units um to the rear um um that uh large
um um it looks like a door but it's
actually a louvered panel uh it is to to
to that which which is set out in the
report where there will be um it will be
blanked off predominantly except for
where there will be the uh uh Inlet and
and the exhaust uh for again any of the
fumes but also including the mitigation
of any odor um through that
panel and we have
photographs again these are the these
are the condensing units as um I I I I
know members are aware they they have
been installed uh but they will be
enclosed as per the proposed drawings I
mean these these these these photographs
were taken a while
ago and that's the uh Lou panel which I
was discussing there is the the the the
rear Doorway to the
right and here we just have some
photographs again as everyone knows
Works had been carried uh out uh during
this period uh but some photographs have
been taken of how the works have
progressed and the nature of the layout
so
far again just on on that this is just
to point out that part of the works was
to um uh expose the the the original
roof and to um uh restore and and make
good uh this is part of the wor which
have been taking
place again just some more of how detail
and have has been restored that the
decoration um uh
installed
so there any more just scr okay so
that's really to give a a
flavor so
um so plan permission is sought for five
condenser um units contained within a
four-sided acoustic louid enclosure and
one number Cellar cooler condenser unit
similarly contained uh within an
acoustic uh
enclosure um the listed building
application comprises full internal
alterations and refurbishment full
details of the components of the
proposal are at
3.1.5 of the report including bar
toilets kitchen and the extraction and
ventilation
system the next section really is just
for
clarification um in terms of the use of
the
property section 3.1.5 of the report
discusses the previous
uses those being as a Morrison and a
post office before that both these uses
fell within class A1 of the previous
iteration of the 20 7 Town and Country
planning youth classes
order in
2020 the use classes or order was
overhauled involving the removal and
replacement of use
classes classes a one 2 and three were
Amalgamated and I'm sort of generalizing
um there bits and pieces of them um into
a new class E as such
shops you High Street type
shops and restaurants now fall within
the same
class and permission to
move from a shop to a Cafe Restaurant
was no longer
required as a
result the change of use within the use
class is one which is permitted by the
development
order so therefore no planning
permission is required
ired the planning application therefore
is only for the condenser and cooling
units and the coroller is that no
objection can be raised to the use of
the premises as a food and eating
establishment the application States the
opening hours are 9 to 11 Monday to
Sunday in terms of the condenser and
Cellar cooler units the proposals have
been assessed by our Environmental
Health Service and found to be
satisfactory in reaching that position
officers are satisfied with the position
of the condenser units on the
ground yeah sorry uh the position of the
condenser units on the ground adjacent
to the external eastern wall in addition
the submitted noise management plan
includes details of the the acoustic
enclosure to the condenser unit which
will attenuate any noise from the units
to within acceptable
standards details of the noise and odor
mitigation for the kitchen ventilation
including the blanking of the Lou except
for the active kitchen vent fresh uh air
Inlet and exhaust connections are
similarly acceptable to prevent nuisance
from the low level discharge and intake
of the system and again just to remind
these are located to the rear wall of
the building which is away from where
the residential are located which is
towards the the opposite
end in respect of the listed building
works the activity which is largely
taken placed prior to approval has been
monitored and assessed by the council's
listed buildings and conservation areas
officer and found to um involve large
Lely um Works to the modern fabric of
the
building and not the original
architectural context or original Fabric
and as such the work that is carried out
and you can see with the photographs
there uh preserves is sympathetic and
consistent with the gradient of the
building in particular the proposal to
reexpose the decorative roof are
welcomed although the works had taken
place prior to approval no detriment was
found and as such there was no need to
carry out enforcement action to seize
the
works as stated above uh planning
permission is not required for the use
of the premises as a food and eating
establishment and the operation could
have commenced except for the
installation of the condensing
units furthermore The Taking of formal
enforcement action is normally a last
resort and only where negotiation and
discussion has failed or clearly
unacceptable Works have taken place uh
we found that uh negotiations had been
successful and no unacceptable Works had
taken
place uh although not part of the
application details the applicant has
submitted details of their noise
complaints and nasm procedures and
confirmed there will be no external sea
in
area that ends a presentation thank you
chairman uh thank you very much Mr
Johnson and we have public participants
for this planning application and in
line with the public participation
scheme I now invite them to read out
their
submission there are uh three so we'll
start with Mrs Wright and then on to Mr
Panton and then on to the agent Mrs
Russell uh so could we have please Mrs
Wright um okay so if you can press the
button which canel laging is y that's
good so on the screen you'll see there
is a clock which you've now seen once
before so when you're ready if you start
and then the clock will start counting
down thank you Mrs Wright we object to
this planning application being contrary
to policies D1 and D3 of the local
development plan the work has already
been completed therefore the planning
applications are incorrect and should be
refiled under Section 73a as
retrospective this establishment will be
have a direct effect on the numerous
neighboring properties noise privacy and
vehicles in Bull Lane this restaurant
and bar will be open seven days a week
all day long until late this will have a
significant impact on our well-being and
quality of life the vast single glaze
windows will allow noise to penetrate
into the immediate neighborhood the
fumes and noise from the kitchen
extractor will affect all residents of
borain this case is no different from
Luigi's at that the limes that should be
treated with the exact same scrutiny the
Old Post Office plats are particularly
concerned about the access to their
properties from the fire exit and
smokers to the shared area we are
disappointed in all local departments
and local authorities that this
conversion was allowed to be completed
with little or no intervention we call
for this application to be rejected
thank you thank you Mrs
Wright um right can we move on then to
uh Mr Panton
thank you so if you could come and uh
take the seat being
vacated and again uh if I just remind
you you can see the clock so when you
start you will have two minutes okay
thank you your
time my name is njel Panton I represent
the Freehold owners of 4345 High Street
molden um and I've been advising them
since their purchase the property is
laying empty for nearly eight years now
and despite all efforts to let the
building um we came up a great against
major problems with uh the condition of
the inside and outside of the building
and the fact it's grade two listed um
the owners the current owners my clients
have carried out extensive work to
refurbish the external fabric at the
rear main
hall and uh we have been approached by
lounges about 18 months ago um because
they could see the potential for
refurbishing the inside which is also a
lot of that has been down to my client's
expense as well this building needs to
be brought back into life has always
been a commercial use and will do will
enhance the vitality and viability of
the High Street in
molden thank you thank you very much Mr
Panton okay and then finally uh Mrs
Russell and again I'll just remind you
there you've seen it now twice there's a
clock there so as soon as you start
that'll start counting down and you have
two minutes thank you uh thank you chair
I'm the planning agent for the
applications um as you will have seen
from the committee papers and heard
tonight um you've heard a detailed
description and assessment of the
applications that are in front of you
you should have also received some
correspondence directly from the
applicant in relation to some of the key
issues which have been the focus of some
of the objections to the proposal so
I've just got a couple of really brief
points to make um as has been mentioned
the applications before you are for
planning and listed building consent for
the internal fit out and the
installation of the external plant
equipment um plus advertisement consent
the use of the premises is already
permitted under the extent planning
application planning permission at the
site and does not comprise part of the
applications a premises license was
granted back in May with no objections
received so the key planning
considerations for assessment tonight
are the impact of the physical works on
the listed building and the impact of
the pro proposed condenser unit
equipment on local immunity with regard
to the impact on the listed building as
you've heard the applicants engaged
extensively with the Heritage officers
who are content that the works present
no harm to the listed building or its
surroundings the offic has visited the
site several times to assess the
proposals and has no concerns
the applicant fully acknowledges that
much of the works have been undertaken
prematurely um in advance of the
applications being determined and fully
accepts that this is not standard
approach and should not have been
done with regard to the plant and
extract this has been designed to
minimize any impact in terms of noise
and odor and noise impact assessments
been undertaken the measures identified
in the report and endorsed by the eho
were incorporated into the design um the
eho has also visited the site several
times and is confident that the
proposals are acceptable um in summary
it's considered that the sythetic
refurbishment of the building will
enable it to be brought back into
beneficial use having been vacant for a
considerable length of time and adding
to the vitality and viability of the
High Street um the proposed occupation
of the building will also bring economic
benefits employing 30 new members of
staff and represents an opportunity to
secure investment in the cent of
molden um the application Proposal
complies with all re relevant policies
of the local development plan and there
are no material considerations or
planning policy grounds which we
consider that would justify planning
permission being withheld um thank you
very much uh thank you very much Mrs
Russell spot on two
minutes okay uh members I now invite you
to put any questions or make any
comments you have on the report
members councilor Lagan thank you chair
just um a couple of points at Mr Johnson
if I may um you talk about when the
change of class happened so the actual
work that was undertaken didn't need
planning
permission um I think that was what we
made clear and that's quite clear in the
report that the dec yeah so we don't
need to do that anymore and the only
thing we're considering is the condenser
units which are in in in place at this
moment and meets all the requirement
required standards that are put in for
noise mitigation um and the application
therefore meets all legal requirements
there's no material reasons to to that
we could turn this this down if if
members would wish to do so so it ticks
all the boxes with regard to the the
requirements under planning
legislation that is correct councelor
lean thank you you councelor Nick
spenley thank you chair um so I refer to
paragraph
5.2.4 in item s so this This concerns um
deliveries to the premises um and
apparently the agent has has confirmed
that the applicants happy to agree to
limiting deliveries between 8: and 6:00
p.m. now I assume with any SE um classy
use deliveries would happen whether it
was retail or restaurant um and it's
good to see that there is some limit on
on deliveries but how could
consideration be given to the periods
when residents might be setting off for
work or returning from work so between 8
and 9 5 and six say when they might find
difficulty in accessing their
premises again because of the nature um
of this application in that you know
planning permission is required for the
use we have no control over those
matters it would be as if any other use
or even under the previous use class the
Morrison um would have occupied that and
carried out their
deliveries um we under this application
um where where um I was encouraged by
the fact that lounges as a as a as a
larger establishment have a protocol in
terms of how they uh um carry out their
business um with neighboring residents
um uh as said earlier they have their uh
noise management plan their neighborhood
liais an officer to try and mitigate
some of these issues and listen to
concerns uh that's about as far as we
can go in terms of supporting that thank
you thank you councelor Paula
spenley well I have to say that I think
it's most unfortunate that the works
have been carried out before the
planning permission has been sought and
I think that that has caused huge um
issues with the local community that
having been said um Mr Johnson I would
ask um for confirmation from you as to
whether or not the fact that it's
retrospective can be taken into
consideration in this because my belie
my understanding is that as you've as
you've indicated that it that that that
isn't a planning consideration tonight
so I just want to be sure of that thank
you Johnson that is correct I would
confirm that that that is a position uh
and then again just to be clear I know
sometimes you know we mention about um
um Works being carried out without
planning permission uh it's not unlawful
to carry out Works without planning
permission um it may become unlawful if
an enforcement notice is served if those
works are unacceptable or non-compliant
with polic
policy thank you chair thank you Mr
Johnson any other questions from Members
or
comments no uh councel
late thank you chairman I just draw
attention to paragraph
5.1.6 which obviously my colleague my
colleagues have mentioned um the
comments from Tim Howen that work should
um it's quite clear that he does not
want work the officer does not want
start work started and then have to go
back there could be potential risk to
the applicant or any applicant that that
does this so we don't want to set a
precedent given the history of the town
that grade two listed buildings are
altered and then seeking forgiveness
later for work that's undertaken so I
think it's an important point to
emphasize that that process should have
engaged the officer first and that
should not have been started which is
the emphasis of of the other councilors
here thank
you thank you councel any no sorry uh
members of the public can't speak at
this point so there's been three
opportunities for members of the public
to speak and and that is it I'm afraid
in terms of our procedures um any other
comments from
counselors Council lagen J kind let me
come
back you try and look at these things
and the liaison has been
poor let's face it I think that the that
the whole of the situation with lounges
could have been so much better at they
lay a with the residents above it
because you know that to me if you if
you engage people you and explain the
whole process what what you can make a
decision upon and what you can't make a
decision upon people were understanding
so I think when we received as as
members received a letter of correspond
respondents from lounges themselves
basically saying that they regret um the
processes that they said well that's all
very well and good saying that to us but
it really needs to be said to the the
residents um and I'm pleased that at the
end of the day the agent has actually
mentioned that in in their presentation
to us so I think something to learn like
councilor Leia said we need to learn
from this you know and the process that
we work in is the planning process and
it's very very strict so thank you thank
you councelor lagen uh yes as as as
you've heard Mr Johnson say we we have
to apply uh planning policy to to the
decision making that we've got this
evening though we recognize some issues
in terms of the process however any
other uh any other questions or comments
otherwise do is there a proposal we've
had a proposal that this is accepted by
the
officers uh do I need a propose proposer
for that or can I just go for a second
for that since we've had a proposal
that's I need a proposal for accepting
that planning application thank you
under section one we approve thank you
very much councelor lay second can we
have a vote to accept this planning
application please those in
favor unanimous okay thank you very much
okay we now move on to agenda item
eight and again uh Mr Johnson could you
take us through this application
please thank you thank you chairman um I
think this probably would be quite
brief
um uh this this application uh comprises
advertisment I'm taking the
advertisement and the listed buildin
application for the advertisements as
one
um advertisement and listed building
consents are sought for the installation
of signage uh change it to external
materials including the repainting of
doors and windows and some glazing minor
glazing
alterations the signage comprises of one
externally illuminated fascia sign which
would be located above the main entrance
door on the front which is a southern
elevation
[Music]
um of the property
uh one externally illuminated hanging
sign and one internally illuminated menu
board which would both be uh which would
uh also be located on the front
elevation the lifted building and
conservation officer has advised that
the proposed signage including a a
modestly scaled Halo lit uh individual
metal lettering and a trough um lit
painted uh Timber hanging sign uh
together with an internally illuminated
menu board would be
sympathetic to the character of the
listed building and the
area um uh he appreciates that a degree
of Illumination would be justified uh
due to the intended restaurant
use uh the proposed advertisements are
considered to be appropriate for the
area uh due to its location the adverts
would uh not harm the character and
appearance of the building in accordance
with policies D1 and D3 of the LD p and
um can see
um the uh advertisements there if we
just have a just quickly just quickly
scroll through sorry you may have done
it while I was looking down so
apologies I think they they're fairly s
just just I mean they're fairly
self-explanatory um but if members want
any more detail about them in their
deliberations we can we can go back to
any one of the um slides there thank you
chairman thank you very much um we have
public participants for this planning
application so in line with the public
participation scheme I now invite them
to read out their
submissions uh so firstly again Mrs
Wright
uh right okay you are down to for this
particular planning application as well
you have an opportunity to or not you've
if it's the same as you said before then
that's fine okay then in that case um uh
there's no need to to read that again
and also uh the um I think this is the
applicant or the agent Mr John
Berle the yeah okay so it will be the
same as well well okay in which case
thank you very much so um members uh I
now invite you to put any questions or
make any comments I think councelor
Miller you had your hand up
before thank you chair where's the post
box on the drawings it's still there
there but on the the drawings just saw
there's no post
box that's there then on the photo but
on the on the drawings it's not there I
assum it's not being moved no not thank
you the might there overstepping of the
market but is it not in is it not in the
way of the side on the left of the door
would it all get in the way of that sign
that we got to the the door the left as
we look at
it that one there would the post box not
be in the way no oh it's close okay
thank you okay thank you uh any other
Council
Lagan well I think because it's such a
an important and iconic building I I
think that what the thought that's gone
into the signage is is very good um
there's been some interesting uses of
that building in my time and being born
here I've seen it um since I walk the
streets as a kid um the gell signs from
previous occupiers other parts of the
High Street have some very um
interesting Livery let's put it that way
a Conservation Area
but I think that this doesn't Overkill
um obviously illumination worries a
little bit for residents above but I
think they've thought of that um i' like
to commend them on their choice of
colors and the way that they've thought
about that okay thank you councilor
Lagan any other cancer
Jennings thank you um can you just point
out where exactly the um externally
illuminated hanging sign would
be well that that's the cafe bar sign
lamp yeah there's a lamp there that's
there
already but where is the um illuminated
hanging sign where is that going to be
situated that
one yeah you just
it where where on the
building all right the end there oh
okay can't see the point of that okay
the entrance has enough it's just thank
you uh any other questions or comments
from
members do we have a proposal in that
case councelor
lagen I propose we accept the officer's
recommendations do we have a second for
that councilor Lei I second that thank
you very much can we have a vote then
please
members unanimous thank you very much
okay carried um on to
then uh agenda item
nine found on pages
53-
62 uh Mr Johnson please could you
present this
report um I
I I I took the yeah I would take I've
separated it I because it's a separate
we need to take a vote on this so you
can just remind people of what this is
and then we can take a vote on this as
well yes
um thank you thank you chair
um the presentation um comprise both the
listed building and the uh advertisement
uh elements of of this proposal uh
agenda item nine is specifically the
advertisement I've given the
presentation um on the details of that
um and really the the just a summary of
of what I've said previously is that the
uh advertisements are considered to be
appropriate for the area and due to the
location of the advert they will not
harm the character and appearance of the
building in accordance with policies D1
and D3 of the ldp thank you chairman
thank you Mr Johnson uh members any
comments some of you have raised
commented newway last time but any any
comments Mr councilor bwood um I just
want to be 100% clear because it seems
to been a little bit of what we actually
voted for because that last vote was for
the signage which was
that agenda item nine uh agenda item
eight I think was the
frontage okay so specifically agenda
item nine refers to
advertisements right I was just getting
a lovely thank you thank
you any other uh comments from Members
or
questions no can we have is there a
proposal then councilor lagin again it
might as well be consistent do I've got
the recommend to accept the officer's
recommendations okay thank you councelor
lagin councelor Jennings are you
seconding that okay thank you could we
remember have a vote then please those
in
favor thank you
unanimous okay we now move on to item 10
uh any other items of business that the
chair decides are Urgent you'll be glad
the answer to that is none so at
8:21 uh I close the
meeting thank you very much can I remind
me